- So you, you bought Simon
this, which is amazing.
- [Howie] Oh, where are we funny?
- [Kelly] Which, by the way, wait,
I would totally ride that. That looks fun.
- [Howie] Me too. I
bought one for myself too.
I get it.
- [Kelly] I, I would do, yeah
- I would do it. You, you, you know what?
You, I don't know if you should do it,
but I can do it, cause you're
like single now, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- So I
- Wait, are single people
not allowed to ride bikes?
- No, but just a single
person on a tricycle
is not as attractive.
(crowd laughing)
- What?
- No, I'm not. I'm not making any-
- What does that mean?
- Maybe more from men.
Like if I was a single guy,
and I wanted to date, or
I wanted to meet somebody,
there's no way I'd be
sitting on a tricycle going,
look at me, look at, you
know, it just doesn't.
- No, but here's the thing.
See? Well, one, I'm
not trying to pick up a
- But, I would always
be wearing protection.
- But
(clapping)
- Well, one, I'm not
trying to pick up anybody,
but if I were, I would
want a man that would
look at me on that and
go, "she seems fun".
- Really?
- [Kelly] Because I'm on a
tricycle, and I've probably got
- Yeah, I don't know if fun's the word.
- I am fun.
- [Howie] No, I, you're fun.
I wasn't talking about you.
I'm saying, seeing a, a, a
lovely lady on a tricycle
- Really?
- Really? Have you ever heard,
I live here in California,
and I go down to Venice beach,
but, I have never heard,
and I have a lot of single friends.
I have never heard, oh, you should seen
this lady on a tricycle yesterday.
- You've never seen
- [Howie] Oh my, she had a basket,
- You've never seen me on a tricycle.
- [Howie] Whoa. And she didn't
even know I hopped on back.
She had no idea I was there. Huh?
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- You can. It's just not a good look for a
- It's. I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna make a video and
I'm gonna send it to you.
- [Howie] Please do.
- Cause I'm gonna look good.
- I'll tell you, it'll go viral on TikTok.
- [Kelly] Just say
- Kelly on a trike.
- [Kelly] And then I'm gonna
send it to Simon and go look,
this is how you do it.
- [Howie] Yes, this is. He's got it.
But I mean, you gotta
give him props, you know,
to get when you fall off a
bike to get right back on.
- Yeah.
- And fall off again.
- Well I was
- [Howie] To fall off a bike
the second time they save you,
to fall down, you should
try to fall down again.
So you're not afraid of falling down.
- He's, he is jinxed with a bike.
I was like maybe try another,
maybe try a scooter, you know, escape.
- [Howie] That's another thing.
That's that's like one up in the
in the motor, motorized vehicle industry.
The scooter is the tricycle.
- [Kelly] No like a little Vespa,
like a little Vespa scooter.
- Why do you say it like that?
- I don't know. Vespa. I
feel like I'm in a Tuscan,
under the Tuscan sun, you know? And I'm
- You shouldn't, it all goes together.
Vespa. It's not Ves-pa. Ves-pa.
- I know, but in my world
- You're making much more out
of the second syllable than it
- I think what we've discovered is,
we would never date in any realm.
(laughing)
You don't want me on a tricycle,
you don't like how I say Vespa.
- No, I want you with me all the time.
I don't want you riding off
into the sunset on a tricycle.
- On a tricycle?
- No, I
- On a Vespa?
- I like you a lot, are
you taking it seriously?
- Oh my God. No, I would hug you,
but you don't like to hug people.
- No, I don't wanna be hugged.
But that's, but that's the way.
(crowd laughing)
- Oh my God. I'm totally kidding.
No, I'm totally kidding. Wait,
- Kidding about what?
- What can you,
- You don't wanna hug me?
You wanna hug me? We could spoon.
- No,
- That way I'm not facing you.
- I only spoon for so long.
- Come on, gimme a hug, gimme a hug.
- Let's talk about it.
Let's talk about it.
(crowd cheering)